what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the chat on the channel
keisha piert
hi
thank you
thanks for coming um
so the reason i found keisha is that i
actually saw her tick tock um of getting
really excited to have a boyfriend i
just thought it was like the cutest like
i'm gonna i'm gonna show the
oh my gosh how do i share my script
i'm gonna show the video
and then
okay
i don't know if we can hear my sound
oh my gosh can i not let me see
i totally thought they'd be able to um
can you guys hear it in the chat let me
know if you can hear my screen
okay i don't know if i'm supposed to
hear it too i don't know if i'm not
supposed to hear then that's fine
like
can you hear it or not i couldn't hear
it that's why i thought maybe they
couldn't hear it oh it's all right
um they'll have to take my word for it
it was really cute
um so i wanted it to
oh just fine so far okay so do you want
to introduce them
go back
with them okay wait i'm sorry why don't
you introduce your channel um so you
have a tick tock account i do have a
tick tock account
maybe i'll get some new maybe i'll get
some new followers from this yeah i'm
going to put all your stuff in the
description and um so why did you start
like talking about like dating tick tock
so when i first joined tick tock first
of all i was like i'm not going to get
on tick tock this is dumb i'm in my 30s
and then one day i got on and realized i
was scrolling for hours i was like okay
so then i wanted to start posting and i
kind of didn't really know
where to start and i the thing i noticed
about tic tocs you kind of have to have
a niche um some people get lucky with
like random videos but i found that you
kind of really have to have a niche i've
been dating in new york for so many
years and i have a lot of stories so i
thought
let's just try this see
see if there are people that'll watch a
lot of things that were coming up on my
for you page were a lot about dating so
i feel like that was kind of a sign to
kind of
talk about dating and so when i started
doing like my dating updates it was more
so of a place of like
therapy in a sense because i feel like
dating can be very frustrating
especially if you live in a major city
like new york and you're using the
dating apps it gets frustrating so for
me it was a way to be like you know what
i'm gonna kind of talk about my dating
and like maybe people will listen but
it's a way for me to get it out there
without like getting too much in my head
and then i realized people were kind of
following along and enjoying it and then
it kind of took off from there
so what challenges did you find dating
in new york i've heard terrible things
why is new york so much worse than the
rest of the country
um i think it's not necessarily just new
york i think it's any one of the major
cities so for sure i would say new york
and la probably have similar issues the
main issue that i've noticed from dating
in new york is there's just way too many
options that's i think the problem
number one the other major issue i
noticed is people move to new york if
they don't live here people move to new
york because they move here for their
career so people are very
career focused so that becomes the
priority and then they kind of put
dating on the back burner so people
might be going on dates but they're like
i'm too busy i don't have time like i
don't they don't want to put in the time
to date because they're laser focused
but i'm like you go out and hang out
with your friends you have a social life
you could also do the same thing for
dating but i think people just kind of
use it as an excuse but you know i love
that about new york that people are so
driven but that's a hard part is people
are really focused on their career
and most people don't really settle down
in new york until they're in their 30s
or 40s which is unlike other places i
grew up in florida
almost all my friends are like married
with kids on multiple kids and they were
kind of settling down in their mid-20s
and if you don't live in a place like
new york people don't quite understand
how you could be in your 30s and still
very single
and if you live here you understand
you're like oh
people are just career focused but yeah
most people don't think about it until
they're in their 30s or 40s which just
makes dating a little bit harder if
you're someone who's like late 20s and
you're like i know i'm ready for
something but no one else is so then
you're kind of sifting through the pool
hoping you find someone who's also ready
to settle down with you
did you so when did you move to new york
i moved to new york in 2012 so i just
celebrated nine years in new york
okay so how old would that would be
when i moved to new york i was 26.
exactly i'll be i'll be 36 this year so
i was like 26 going on 27 when i moved
to new york
okay so it was like you were kind of in
a place where you moved to new york
where you were ready to settle down and
you just felt like the dating pool
wasn't
um i thought i was ready to settle down
looking back
i thought
then that i was ready for a relationship
um i've been single for a lot chunk of
my life i was a late bloomer in life i
didn't have my first boyfriend until i
was 26. that was right before i moved to
new york i worked in a cruise ship and
we broke up because it was long distance
and we didn't want to do it so i moved
to new york and i knew that i really
enjoyed being in a relationship even
though it was short term i still enjoyed
that so i was like you know i feel like
i'm ready to meet my my person so i kind
of put myself out there but looking back
now i wasn't the best version of me for
that relationship and i didn't know it
at the time so i was just you know going
on dates you know really actively trying
to meet someone and just
not having any luck so it was just
a lot of frustration
and when you say like the you weren't
the best version of you like what were
there mistakes that you made like why do
you say that
yeah so um i think the main things i
realized is i think
my mindset wasn't in the right place i
think because i was a late bloomer in
life like i didn't really date till i
was in my mid-20s and having been single
for most of my life i had a mindset of
like i'm gonna be single forever i'm
never gonna meet anyone and whether we
believe it or not those kind of thoughts
do mirror your reality around you so
even though i knew i wanted to be in a
relationship deep down i secretly
thought i'm never gonna find someone
like i'm gonna be alone forever so
that kind of carried with me a lot in my
dating and i didn't know it at the time
until i started going to therapy and
realizing a lot of these things about
myself so i think that was it also i
think i was just i was so hung up on
like every date i went on so many dates
being like is this the last first date
i'm going on and that should never be
that should never be your michael coming
in but at the time i don't know i didn't
really know a lot of things i was naive
i was still new to dating um so i didn't
know a lot of these things but i just
went in with a completely wrong mindset
um and i've always been a pretty
positive person most of my life but i
realized it wasn't always coming from an
authentic place
and so i had to learn to truly just be
happy with myself
single or not whether i meet a partner
in life or not like before i met my
boyfriend it's like i have a great life
i've created a great life if i never
find a partner like i still have an
amazing life but i didn't quite have
that mindset when i first moved to new
york it's like i've built this life for
myself but deep down i always was like
had that like worry or that pit and you
really have to learn to be happy by
yourself no matter what because if
you're dwelling on the fact that i'm
alone and nobody wants me like it's just
not good energy to carry around
so yeah that was definitely one of the
mistakes i made i just approached dating
all wrong it's not a good thing to
appreciate well we even talked about how
um
were you part of the like men or trash
um you know camp at all during this time
no i don't think i ever really
okay men were trash per se and i know
what you're talking about because
there's a lot of women who fully are
like man-hating and i'm like
how do you like you like how do you
expect to find a man if you're fully
like hating them so i was never really
on the men are trash it was just so much
frustration with not meeting good men
so then i guess i guess in a way i guess
i lied i guess in a way there were parts
of me that were like ah there's no good
men left out there but i wasn't
necessarily screaming like i hate men
men or trash
like
are there still good men out there and i
think that's a little bit different than
like men or trash yeah i think i think
there's a fine line it can kind of cross
over a little bit but it definitely
wasn't like i hate men men are stuck
like there's no need for that i
definitely was not on that being wagon
but i definitely for a while thought to
myself like there's no good men left
like how where are people meeting their
partners like there's no good men left
and you you kind of have to get out of
that because it will follow you like
that
carries with you
well that's like one of the biggest
mistakes i think i see women make in
dating where they're just like really
frustrated
um and they'll just they'll just say
like
things that are so rude like towards men
like men are trash like they're the
problem like
i hate men whatever and i'm just like
that we would not accept that if they
said that about women you know
exactly and i see so many tick tocks
have like so much negative energy around
dating which is why like once i started
realizing what worked for me and my this
might not work for everyone but i've
tried a lot of the other things which is
why i think some of the things that i
did
are better ways to go about it but i see
so much negative tick tocks and that's
why now my focus is to help other people
find that you know amazing partner or
like at least give them tips to be like
hey you can find what you want you just
gotta have to stay open and be positive
and like i know it's frustrating but
like don't my thing is like don't give
up because your person's out there and
some people meet their person later in
life and some people meet them early in
life
but i feel like there is someone out
there for everyone i know people don't
always believe that but i do believe
there's someone out there for everyone
if that's what you want so i'm like now
trying to help people
not make mistakes i made because i feel
like that set me back a lot but you know
you learn from everything and
this is part of my journey and i have no
regrets no matter what
well it's interesting i actually i
disagree with something you said
so i don't think there's a person for
everyone i think there's a person for
everyone if you make the correct life
choices
uh okay yeah so you know what i mean so
like for example um like one thing that
i don't think like as women we're really
like honest about with each other
sometimes is like if you gain a lot of
weight less guys are going to be
interested you know that i mean it's
part of life i don't like it you know
right it is but
right and it's like
i think that the choices we make like
dictate the type of partner we get
rather than like having one person like
out there for everyone so like for
example if you want a fit partner like
you have to be in shape yourself you
know
or um if you want like a friendly
partner you have to be friendly yourself
like i really think like we get what we
put out in the world
yeah i will i will agree with you in
that in some sense i do say
like i agree with your statement of like
there's not there might not be someone
out there for you based on like how you
change what you say is i believe that
there are always going to people be
people who like you
as you are it may not be the people
you're attracted to that's what i feel
so like i do that there's always going
to be someone who finds you attractive
and like wants to be with you but if
you're someone like first that's like
unhappy with your body or things like
that
the partner the partners that you want
may not be the people that you want so
if that makes sense so i feel like
there's always gonna be something for
you that it might not be the person that
you want for yourself and i think that's
where people have to understand like for
instance i live a fit and active
lifestyle i don't necessarily need a
partner who's like at the gym set like i
don't need a sick i don't need to be
with a partner who's a six-pack abs and
all that some people that's important to
them so yeah they're probably
surrounding themselves at like crossfit
or the gym
for other people you'll see partners
where one person's really fit and one
person's not as fit but they may still
do active things together so i think
also understanding like what is
important for you it's not always
important for the other person but you
do have to understand that there will
always be someone that likes you but it
may not be the people that you have and
that's what you have to understand so i
agree
that's actually really true there's no
way because as girls that's so true
there is always someone that likes you
as as a girl i think not all guys right
as a girl and it's but it's not always
going to be the person you like back and
you have to understand if there's
something you don't like about yourself
you have the power to change it don't
just sit in this woe as me
and you have to want to do it for
yourself that's the key you can't want
to do it
to retract a partner you can't want to
do it for some other reason you have to
do it for yourself because then it's
never going to stick and then when you
start making changes with yourself and
you're happy then you know like you said
the things around you will start to
mirror that yeah no that's that's so
true um
okay so you said what you were looking
for in a partner um have you always been
looking for the same thing in a partner
or did that change over time
i feel like that changed over time um
i i don't i don't think i was specific
enough in what i was looking for a
partner when i first started dating in
new york i just knew like i want a
boyfriend i want to be in a relationship
i'm going to go on dates and like hope
to meet my person and so i was just kind
of going on dates and like you know for
me i was someone who like had their glow
up later in life like i feel like i look
at pictures of myself in high school or
like early college and i'm like
just you know but that's that's my story
so for
when i started getting attention from
guys when i had my glow up i never
really had that kind of attention before
so when i first started dating i kind of
was going for ego to be like
these are people i was attracted to when
i was younger who never gave me the time
of day and now i'm getting it like i
know that that's part of what it was
early on as i was kind of like trying to
boost my ego a little bit which isn't
always the best way to go about dating
and i have no regrets about that it is
nice to have an ego just to be like wow
this person is like hot like i've been
out with some people that i'm like
like okay you know did you what do you
mean a glow up did you like lose a lot
of weight or something no because you're
you're like clearly in great shape like
yeah
in your arms i'm in great shape now like
i work out now i live in an active
lifestyle now but i wasn't always that
way i was like a band geek in high
school i was a nerd i was a little bit
heavier i was never like fat per se like
if you looked at me like i'm curvy so
i've always had a big butt like it's
just small smaller now that i've like
gotten in shape but you know it's a
little you know a little extra meat on
my bones but i was never like
obese or fat or anything like that you
know why you if you look at pictures of
me even from
10 years ago you can see my face is a
little bit rounder you can see the
difference between the two but i decided
to adopt a healthy lifestyle once i
graduated college and i wanted to do it
for me because it's like i was eating a
lot of fast food i just wasn't eating
the healthiest and then i started
pursuing acting and i also you know high
blood pressure runs in my family
diabetes runs in my family so part of it
was for health reasons i didn't want to
have to worry about those things um and
then i started taking care of myself and
it's like oh i feel better and i look
better and i like
living an active lifestyle
but let's be honest if i was always a
hundred pounds growing up i probably
wouldn't give a crap about what i ate
you know like
but i'm glad that i do have to live an
active lifestyle so i'm not just eating
crap all the time because i like i
splurge a good like in moderation but
even sometimes when i explore just like
i just feel
gross because you know when you're not
used to eating that stuff but i now take
good care of myself just because it's
something i pride like it i like it for
myself but uh i wasn't necessarily like
an ugly duckling per se but i just feel
like you can look at old photos of me
and you're like okay
um
wait so
you said your type so at first you were
chasing more of like the good looking
guys and then it switched so i've always
so she i was kind of chasing good
looking guys but i don't you know i like
nerdy guys too like i i feel like i tell
people i was like you gotta go for like
the super cute nerd because they're like
they're they don't have a crazy ego
they're also very nice people and like
everyone needs love too so i feel like
yes it's nice to like have the really
hot arm candy but it's not about at the
end of the day i learned it's not always
about looks i feel like people think
it's about looks and like you have to be
the most beautiful woman on the planet
and you have to be for guys maybe they
think like oh girls need to have a
six-pack it's not about that like yes
you want to feel good about yourself and
take care of yourself but it's really
like who are you as a person like how do
you carry yourself and are you meeting
someone who like matches that energy and
has those same goals
so i think
you know i do kind of have it
my friends are like you like to date men
who walk it look like they walked out of
a banana republic catalog and i was like
you're not wrong
but so i do like have a type per se but
even with that
it's like i really just want to have a
good time with the person and like enjoy
their company generally enjoy their
company but i wasn't specific in what i
wanted for a partner until about two
years ago
um when i
heard someone say like sit down and
write down
all of the qualities you want in a
partner
like what are your core values like you
want because that's really what matters
at the end of the day so i sat down and
i wrote a list of like all the things i
wanted a partner like i want someone
who's super supportive of me and my
career who's very caring who's honest
who's loyal
you know you can you know some women
even get even as specific as like he has
to be
i don't think you need to go specific
where it's like he has to be five six
and taller like for me it's like that
didn't really matter more about what are
the core values that i'm looking for in
a person but i wrote down like two pages
of all the things i truly wanted i
folded it up i put it in an envelope and
i forgot about it i kind of was like
okay the universe knows what i want i'm
just going to kind of take steps towards
these goals and trust that this person
will show up um so that was one of the
things i did and then i also like went
to therapy just so i could be the you
know work through some things i think
everyone has their own
trauma they have to work through and i
think that's so important when you are
trying to build up a life with someone
that it's important that you work out
that stuff before you get in
so you're not bringing all of that with
you
i actually didn't even know that you
went to therapy like that's great i
think therapy is awesome therapy is
amazing i think every single person
should be in therapy whether you've gone
through anything traumatic or not i
think it's just a really good safe space
to talk about life and your feelings but
i still feel like there's this stigma
around therapy not so much anymore i
feel like we're moving in the direction
where it's become more normal but for
years it's almost like if you told
someone you were in therapy they're like
what's wrong with you it's like
therapy is a good it's mental health is
important like mental health matters
and so i'm glad people are moving in the
direction but yeah i went to therapy for
about two years so i think that was from
like 2016 to 2018 i went to therapy and
i had a really great therapist she was
wonderful i loved her a lot
um you know what's so crazy thing i
don't think men are as picky as we think
like
really really like i've been watching
like men's dating content for months and
all they want is someone in better shape
than them whatever they're at just
better shape than them right like
feminine right
and friendly like that's literally it
that's like the three and supportive and
a good person i think you just yeah
they're a good person with good
intentions yeah like there's a lot of
guys that are sick of being used for
their money right because these girls
will use them for like a date with no
intention of ever dating them yeah i
feel like i watched um i don't remember
where i watch this video but i watched
it a couple years ago and there was a
woman who clearly said oh yeah i go out
on dates like
four days like four days a week just to
get free dinner and it boggles my mind
that women are in this gold digger
mindset i'm like why though like you
should don't you have money to take
yourself out to dinner why do you need
to use someone
just to go out together and that's
different than like dating multiple
people with intention and then you may
happen to go on a few dates a week but
there are some women who fully just go
on dates because they want men to pay
for them and i'm like yeah that energy
comes back to haunt you i'm a believer
in that and that's another thing like i
think a lot of like trauma on both ends
would be avoided if we all just dated
intentionally yes like because i think a
lot of times girls kind of wait around
and like hope for something more than
like they're really gonna get you know
and even though like girls gonna be like
oh he didn't tell me but 90 of the time
guys tell us we don't listen you know
what i mean we we hope and like hope for
the best and hope they can change but
like
i think that like dating intentionally
is super important
yes and that's where i started seeing
the shift
was when i started dating intentionally
i don't know how long you've been seeing
my videos but i don't know if you saw
the video i made in december of last
year of me fully crying on tick tock and
i was like i don't even know why i'm
crying this is so dumb i just been
ghosted by a guy and i like was over it
because i felt like i kept getting
ghosted and which ghosting is a cop-out
don't ghost be upfront with your
feelings like we're all adults stop
ghosting that's my yes
but i made a video where i was just
really upset and over it and i was like
you know are there any good people left
and i decided to take a break after that
and like take a break and come and i
took a few months off and came back
refreshed and i started dating more
intentionally meaning like and i
primarily use the dating apps just
because i live in new york city it's
busy also there's a pandemic we can't
meet at the bar like we used to there's
not as many events but once i started
dating more intentionally i started
paying more attention to who i was
swiping on i adjusted my profile so that
if someone looked i wanted it to be so
if someone looked at my profile they
could say like oh wow this person really
looks like they're looking for something
and i want them to be like she looks fun
i want to meet her and i ended up
getting like in all of the people i
dated up until this point they all said
you had such a great profile like i
looked at your photos and i was like you
look like you're someone who's really
fun to hang out with and i want to meet
and so i started just being more
intentional
and i think you have to be because there
are a lot of people who waste your time
and sadly you know people are just on
board and they're looking to stroke
their ego and then it sucks for people
who really do want to meet someone and
are putting themselves out there and
then when you're met with too many
people who are just wasting your time
then you say you know what's the point
and then you kind of give up and
do you wanna you don't know crazy stat
that i found out it's gonna blow your
mind um 20 of men have sexual access to
80 of women so the reason that girls
hate men is because like they're all
sleeping with the same ones
wait say that again so 20 of single men
have sexual access to 80 of women oh
jeez wow so the reason that women like
feel this way about men a lot of times
like there's no good men left is because
we're all going after the same guys
oh
i'm so bad
yeah so 80 of men are not having sex
with anyone
of single men single yeah obviously like
50.
wow
that's not crazy
that's wild that's
crazy that's that's that blew my mind um
okay so
you you went to therapy you started
working on yourself mm-hmm what um
did you feel excited i have a question
for you sometimes i feel like girls at
first have like some superficial
requirements so like height right you
know like height is first one that comes
to my head but money whatever um and
sometimes i feel like a lot of times
they aren't realistic
do you feel like that's a problem that
you see was that ever a problem for you
or no
not really um
i'm the kind of person like i'm an
actress i live in new york city i'm not
making my full income from acting but so
i wait tables to pay my bills but i have
a make a good living but for me i'm
someone that i'm like i don't care what
kind of job you have like as long as you
can support yourself independently
outside of this relationship and you're
not relying on me
i don't care you could be flipping
burgers and if you're making enough
money to support yourself that's fine
but there are so many women that are
like if he doesn't make
per year
or this i won't give him the time of day
i'm like but why though there's so many
good men that like
they're they're financially i feel like
if they're financially stable which is
really all anyone's asking for like be
financially stable and please don't be
living with your parents and like bro
you don't have to live on your own
because i live in new york so it's
common for everyone to live with
roommates just because it's expensive
here so things like that don't bother me
hi
for me on height the only thing for me
that i couldn't do
i'm five six
i couldn't date someone like i've dated
a few people who have five five but any
shorter than that for me i've tried i
like went on a date with a guy a couple
years ago he was so nice but he was 5'4
and i couldn't get over the fact that he
was so short and i was like i felt like
a terrible human being so i'm like is
this that i'm like listen some people
have what they have but for me i'm like
i don't care about
that per se i'm like as long as you're
at least my height or taller i'm like it
doesn't matter to me the only other
thing for me is like i do work out i
live a healthy lifestyle i could not be
with someone who
was like severely overweight because for
me like the things that i want to do i
just don't know if that person would be
able to get out with me
so for me those were the two main things
is like i don't need someone to be going
to the gym every day but i do help the
person i'm with like
does take care of their body and you
know maybe you work out two days a week
or something and you eat someone
splurge on dates for me that was
important for me but i don't need
someone to have a six-pack or things
like that but there are a lot of women
that focus so much on the superficial
aspect and that's not gonna make a
lasting relationship yes well that's
what i really like about you is like i i
talked to a girl in my life the other
day that was asking for a two hundred
thousand dollar engagement right that's
in wait
i wonder if i saw that oh no i feel like
i saw personally about an engagement
ring but maybe that's not it two hundred
thousand dollars
insane and here's and here's the thing
like keisha i don't know how much you
know about my family and stuff like i
come from a family
of your videos and i was like girl like
i remember you doing an outdoor or
something and i was like oh like she's
living the good life
well i'm just saying like i know guys
that can afford this stuff and i don't
but half the times the guys that could
like can't afford this stuff they're
good with their money they're not gonna
spend two hundred thousand dollars on an
engagement ring yeah so so even if you
you were like in front of the the guy
that could afford that right and would
be like willing like wanting to be with
you like half the time like you're gonna
scare him off because you're not gonna
settle for anything less than a 200k
yeah and that also to me hearing that
that to me seems like the women has some
red flags that she needs to work on like
if you're expecting someone to give you
200 000
engagement ring i feel like you need to
go back and kind of figure out
some things because for me it's like if
that's your focus there are more
important things than a 200 000 like i
feel like i was reading a post somewhere
and someone said that her husband bought
her 400 engagement ring and she showed
that thing off to everyone because it
was the ring that she loved and it was
important to her and that's what it's
about it's not about how much money the
man spends on the ring like if he wants
to spend a ton of money on the ring go
ahead but like if you get me a ring that
i like and i love i don't care how much
money it costs because it's like i'm
gonna be marrying you i'm not marrying
the ring
and yeah it's nice to show off a bling
ring but it's like at the end of the day
that's not what it's about so if you're
hung up one well if you won't spend 200
000 but to me that's that's absurd
that's crazy even like girls will be
like for first dates oh coffee isn't a
first date i'm like what's wrong with
coffee
listen first dates should be low-key
well now i've revamped how i do my how i
did my first dates but when i was doing
in-person first dates i'm like a walk in
the park
coffee something very low-key that
doesn't necessarily cost a lot of money
because a if it sucks it's in you're not
tied to dinner or anything
and when you do something low-key if you
do hit it off you can always extend the
date i've been on so many dates where we
started for coffee and we're like oh
we're enjoying our company like do you
want to go grab a drink or go somewhere
else and there you know there's the
natural progression of that but yeah i
know what you mean there are some women
that are like if he doesn't take me
to xyz like i won't even i won't even do
anything but i'm like that's dumb as
long as he's planning the date which he
should if he asks you out don't ask
unless he's like hey i want you to go
where you go and you pick because that's
what um that's what you like we call him
the electrician that's what he did for
our in-person date he goes i want you to
pick your favorite restaurant that you
love in astoria and let's go there and
so for me it's like oh great that's easy
for me but outside of that
as long as the man is planning a date
and he might ask me some suggestions
that's really all it's about who cares
where we're going now unless it's like
if he took me to mcdonald's or something
like that's a different story yeah
unless you both love mcdonald's and
great then that's a great first date if
you both have a love for mcdonald's for
me i'd be like if a guy checking me to
make dollars for a first date for me
personally i might be like uh i don't
know about this i don't eat fast food
and b i'm like why
because it's like it's about the company
it's not about it's not about where you
go it's about like enjoying the company
and the time you're spending together
right but i'm sure you'd be cool with
starbucks and a walk oh i
i've earned tons of coffee dates because
it's low-key it's cheap and sometimes
like i've even paid for coffee on dates
because i'm like hey it's not a big deal
it's like 10 bucks yeah coffee and a wok
ice cream i've done ice cream dates i've
done
a lot i've done like free events new
york does free things all the time i've
done free events on dates
who cares but so many people are so hung
up on the like well he didn't take me to
xyz so like i can't even go out with him
again i'm like well good luck out there
then if that's your mentality
no and that's that's why like your page
was so refreshing to be because i was
like this is a girl she is so excited to
be like dating an electrician like
that's how it should be no like and it's
just you see this delusion online where
they're like i'm not gonna be like show
my man off unless he's the ceo of a
company or all this stuff and i'm like
ladies like
how hot do you think you are i
know be honest at least in new york and
i might get some hate for this but um a
lot of the finance bros in new york are
not at honey they are not it like
like keep moving not saying all
there are some really good financial i'm
sure because a lot of them cheat right
is that what you mean they're just like
not you know they don't always have the
best personalities and things oh okay
okay you know but but right for me it's
like i don't you know
it does it shouldn't matter
like what the person's job is as long as
they're like
financially stable but i know what you
mean there are women out there who like
wouldn't even give some of these jobs
the time of day but i'm like it's a
great trade
so it's it's great
yeah he's only been doing it for about
like going into two years so he's still
new in that but he has somewhere to grow
and like electrician is a really good
skill to have because there is a lot of
work once you like have your skill
finishing up school right now too so
that will help him but yeah so many
women would just kind of like turn off
that
and that's the crazy thing like if i had
to guess like i think the quickest way
to make six figures these days is a
trade like honestly yeah
women don't realize like the trades are
gold like girls have no idea i worked in
plumbing for a little bit i wasn't a
plumber but i worked for freaking
plumbing
um i worked at as like the marketing
person right so i like
i would see these guys like like they
they do well that's nice oh no 100 like
but people but you're told like you got
to go to school and get a degree and all
this but like now i think people are
starting to realize the trades are where
it's at but i like at least when i was
growing up it was like you got to go to
school you got to get into this whereas
now i think more people are kind of
foregoing that you know because there's
a lot of money to be made in some of
these trades so like get your breath
honey
okay um so sorry i keep i like talking
about getting off topic
so you started dating intentionally um
and you feel like that was like what it
shifted for you
do you d intentionally like for marriage
or for a long-term relationship
um both so i am someone i'm like i do
want to be married not tomorrow but you
know i was eating with the fact that
like i do want to be a mom and i do want
to get married like yes i'm 35 and i'm
older but for me i'm like there are
women who are having families later in
life so for me i was like that's like
there's plenty of time still for all
that but for me i know like i want to
get married and have a family someday so
for me that was important and the people
i was going out with eventually i was
like i just want you to know like this
is what what i want down the line not
tomorrow because i think a lot of guys
when they hear a woman say like oh i
want to get married i think a lot of
women a lot of men interpret that to me
but it's not to you it's to with the
right person but i think so many men
here like oh she wants to get married
like oh my god
no they're not saying to you they're
just telling you that down the line
that's what they want and if you know
that's not what you want then let's not
waste each other
from my experience like that only scares
off the guys that don't like want to get
married anytime soon right
um
how i'm just curious how old is your
boyfriend is he older than you he's 31
so i'm older okay
okay i was just wondering because i
found like um
not for me per se but like i've seen
girls say that it's easier when they
date like older than them like the men
tend to be like more serious so i was
just curious if you found that too
you know he yeah he's 31 which is about
the right age i mean we're both in our
30s and he like took time off he like
took a year or two off from dating too
because he just had some bad luck in
relationships and like his lost
relationships in he was telling me like
the girlfriend was like ex-girlfriend
was like not very nice to him and he
kind of put up with it for a long time
he should have left a lot sooner but you
know sometimes when you're in those
situations you don't necessarily know
what to do and then
you realize you should have left a long
time ago but like he realized after that
that he needed to take to take a break
he also went to therapy he like was
working on issues he had to work on for
me that's important too like if someone
i'm dating has never been to therapy for
me i'm like nope you need to go to their
like because everyone has things that
they have to work on and they're
subconsciously bringing into
relationships whether that's romantic
relationships or platonic relationships
whether they believe it or not so i
think everyone should be in therapy and
if you're dating someone and they've
never gone to therapy might be a good
idea to like suggest it to them because
there's a lot of things we always can be
working on so i'm glad that he told me
he'd gone to therapy and he like really
spent time by himself and working on
things that he wanted to work on which i
did the same thing i worked on things
that i needed to work on with myself so
that i could be better for whoever i was
going to meet in the future
um so what other like mistakes and
solutions did you find to dating is
there anything we didn't go over yet
yeah so for me one of the biggest things
that for me personally that's worked for
me i know not everyone agrees with this
but this was a mistake that i felt like
i made way too many times and then i
tried the opposite and it worked for me
so i used to date where i would only
date one person at a time i would go on
a date and like say we've been on a few
dates and it's going really well i would
put all my focus and energy on that
person because i'm like oh we're like
enjoying each other's time we're having
a good time and i would essentially like
laser focus on that one person and then
you start to go down the rabbit hole
like why haven't they texted me i
haven't heard from them like what's
going on you like focus so much
and whether we believe it or not that
hyper focus people can sense that energy
um and i feel like i was doing that so
much and i feel like i was constantly
getting ghosted and i would like people
would just you know stop calling or
things like that and i feel like for me
i would just go down to like anxiety
train and so for me i was like well this
isn't working we need to kind of like
try something else and i stumbled upon a
few dating podcasts and um i love her
podcast it's called single smart female
um i highly recommend it for ladies and
she started talking about she calls it
mantra dating i call it dating multiple
people all means the same thing
basically what it means is you should be
dating multiple people
with intention obviously not just
until you're ready to become exclusive
so that means like even if you've been
on five or six dates with someone you
don't cut off all of your other contacts
you
you know i was up front the whole time
with him i told him from the beginning
like i haven't put all my eggs in this
basket but it doesn't mean i'm not
interested and it doesn't mean i'm not
putting in effort that's the difference
i think people
assume that if you're dating multiple
people that you just don't care and
you're just wasting people's time it's
like no this is what worked for me but i
started talking about mantra dating
where it's like you you should be dating
lots of people to find out what you like
what you don't like and then when you
not when they like it should be when
you're ready
to be exclusive with that person then
you have that conversation together and
if the person brings it up and you're
not ready yet make that clear like hey
like i'm really enjoying your time but
you know i'm just not quite ready to
commit to that but i would still love to
continue this going and and then you
know
some you know the other person might say
like okay well that's not really what i
want and if if that's the case then you
know they're out of the rotation as
people say and then you know yeah
but for me
that started working better because then
i wasn't so focused on if i didn't hear
from
let's just say like if i didn't hear
from brad i'm like oh okay tough luck
like there's two or three other people
that i'm still in that are going well so
it's not a big deal if i don't hear from
someone but if you're only focusing on
one person or only dating one person and
you don't hear from them for days what
do you start doing you start going down
the rabbit hole of like what's wrong did
they die we've all done it
did they die are they ghosting me like
you but it's like this way of dating
keeps it more fun in my opinion when i
was like oh yeah like i'm seeing two to
three really great guys right now and
i'm having a lot of fun and i love this
about this person and i love this person
and i also think it helps you get
clearer about what you want for yourself
in a long-term relationship based on the
people you're seeing because if you're
only going out with one person and you
kind of put all your eggs in that basket
in the beginning you may not see red
flags right away you might not notice a
lot of the things that you would had you
been keeping your options open and for
me if the other way didn't work i was
like i gotta try something else yeah
dating multiple people worked for me
kept it more fun
i almost always had more dates lined up
and it was just a great way to go about
dating for me i know not everyone can
date multiple people because i i get it
it's not for everyone that i am in favor
of everyone should be dating multiple
people until you have an exclusive
conversation with someone so i i
i can't decide if i agree with you or
not i know i know that everyone does
this
for me because i tried the other way
yeah it works no see like okay i think
like the more dates you go on the more
likely you're going to meet somebody
that likes you too
and like you have the same values
whatever you're looking for but at the
same time i do think it's a turn off
when a guy
thinks like a girl is like
talking to so many guys and like getting
all this attention and like needs that
validation but i think what you're
saying is more to just go on dates with
a lot of different people so you can
like find the right person but you don't
really see that
as like
sorry i'm just thinking out loud but i
don't think you're really saying like
that it's like an attention thing it's
just not the right person it's not an
attention thing because we went on nine
dates before we became official and
right before that there was one other
person in the picture we were about to
set up a third date and then obviously
cut it off and then right before that
date i had had two first virtual dates
the week before but they both ended up
unmatching me so that worked out
but so even if i was going like even
before the electrician i was dating
connecticut i don't know if you signing
my updates about him
we were dating
for like three and a half months and we
weren't even official yet and i think
it's deep down because i knew it
probably wasn't a right fit but also i
was just having so much fun dating that
it wasn't
i wasn't so focused on like where is
this going we like kind of talked a
little bit but i was having fun but i
think probably deep down i knew like
this probably isn't gonna work out but
i'm still enjoying his company so i
still wanted to see him so yeah you are
going out you know on six or seven dates
with someone
um
and you
don't really feel comfortable going on
new dates with people then that's also
fine but i also was up front so i was
upfront with the people so that they
knew
and if they had a problem with it then
they could leave because i'm like well
this is how i choose to date this is
what works for me but it doesn't mean
i'm not interested that's the thing i
made it clear it's like just because i'm
dating other people doesn't mean i'm not
interested
it's just i haven't put all my energy in
this basket because you haven't earned
that yet that's where the difference is
right
um i'm just reading these comments do
not like that
i had followers who did not who were not
on my bandwagon i had followers who were
like i don't agree with you but like
good luck
and i think because they think they
think when girls say that that like
girls are sleeping with all these guys
i'm not here's the thing that's and
that's like that's what i think like
guys just like assume yeah so i will
tell you this yes i was dating multiple
people but i was only sleeping with him
and even when we were sleeping together
i did tell him i was like i'm still
dating other people but i'm only
sleeping with you and he made a good
comment he goes you know even if you
were sleeping with other people that's
my problem to have for me that's a
mature answer because for him he's like
well we're not exclusive yet so you
can't be mad so we weren't exclusive at
this time
that we had this conversation so it's
like he couldn't really be mad if i was
but for me i even when i was dating
multiple people i would never be
sleeping with multiple people some
people do that and so
it's really kind of whatever the
personal choice is so right i think a
lot of people think like oh well
if you're dating multiple people then
you're sleeping with all these people at
the same time it's like there might be
some people who date that way and
there's nothing wrong with that but i do
think if you are
dating multiple people and you also want
to be sleeping with multiple people i do
think it's important to make that clear
to who you're dating with so that they
can decide
if they want to go along because like if
i'm if say for instance if i'm dating
multiple people say i'm dating three
guys and i happen to be sleeping with
all three guys i think it's my duty to
say hey i'm also still dating other
people
with them
and then if one of the guys says hey you
know what i'm not really comfortable
with that i would like to take myself
out of this then that's great so for me
i do think if you're gonna do that i
think it is important to be up front
um
just so if someone is not okay with it
they have the choice to walk away i
think that's the only fair way to do it
so right yeah i know but i know not
everyone agrees with the way i dated
i tried the other way i tried the other
way it did not work for me so for me
i was like if i keep running into a same
issue i have to try something else so
that's what made me want to try this way
of dating and it worked yeah
no you're um
again that was like the cutest video of
you just because
and listen he and this is and i know on
tick tock i know a lot of people don't
agree with this but you know the tic toc
saying like if he wanted to he would
i fully was like ladies if he wanted to
he would this man went out and like on
our on our first in-person date because
i started doing virtual dates during
coven on our first in-person date for
dessert we had a reese's peanut butter
pie that we shared so when he asked me
to be his girlfriend he cooked me thai
food he cooked me a chicken satay
appetizer she cooked me vegetable pad
thai he had a bottle of versa prosecco
rose waiting for me and then for dessert
he brought out a reese's ice cream cake
and he wrote on it like to the cutest
girl in the world and he was so nervous
that instead of writing cutest it says
cuddis because he looks
but like that goes to show like he
really put thought and effort into that
and i feel like you don't really see
that as much anymore but i'm like ladies
there are still so many good men out
there you just have to sift through
the trash you do you know
and that's what like a lot of times i
think guys are afraid like i feel like
girls are afraid of being used for their
bodies guys are afraid of being used for
their resources yeah so i see guys like
even in the chat they're like they're
like oh he's beta and that's like what i
hear a lot in the manosphere i was
telling you about it yeah um and that's
that's the thing is
guys a nice like appreciative girl is
not gonna be turned off by do you doing
nice things for her
yeah like like the right girl isn't
there are girls that will use you and
they will take advantage of you that
totally exists but like the right girl
is going to appreciate those things 100
and i feel like i'm naturally i wear my
heart on my sleeve i have a big heart
i'm a very thoughtful person by nature
and in the past especially if i'm like
oh i'm enjoying their company like i'll
go out of my way if i see something that
that makes me think of them
you know i'll go and be like oh i
thought of this you know i thought of
you i got this at the store and i felt
like i would always be doing things for
guys like even if we weren't like
official or anything it's just that's
who i am by nature it wasn't always
appreciated and so a lot of times i'm
like am i doing too much like am i going
too much out of my way and you know
there's the there's the saying on tick
tock if i'm doing too much then find
less which i do agree with if i'm doing
too much then find less but with him
like he brought me flowers on her i
brought him cookies on our fourth date
he brought me flowers on on our fifth
date caught me by surprise then like two
days two or three days ago i was out
with some friends at moment ps1 and i
saw these cat magnets he's a cat dad
he's also a cat dad and i saw these
magnets and i thought of them and i was
like i'm gonna get these for him this is
before we were official and i gave it to
him and he like lit up he was so excited
he's like oh my god thank you so much
and it's like i found someone who
appreciates the things that i've always
wanted to do and i just hadn't met
someone who reciprocated it because i
think where a lot of people fall short
is they want to do those things and
they're not finding the people who also
reciprocate it and that makes it hard
because then you want to put a wall up
and be like well well then i'm never
going to like do anything again or like
i'm never going to tell it because i
operated from the point of like every
time i told the guy i like them this
happened up until this almost every time
i would finally be like okay i like this
guy i'm going to say it i always got
ghosted they always disappeared so for a
long time i was like effort i'm not
going to say anything i'm not going to
tell them how i feel i'm going to still
go out with them but like i'm never
saying i like because it's hard when
you're constantly being met you want to
put up a wall and then i realized
that's not fair to the new people you're
meeting
so
yes it's frustrating and you don't want
to do it but the new person you're
meeting that's not fair to them because
what if that next person is the person
who is going to reciprocate all the
things you've wanted and so i finally
paid myself to be like you know what
i just need to show up authentically and
the right person will appreciate it and
that's where it is great personal
appreciation and that's such a good
that's such a good mindset because so
many times women make men of the like
men of the future pay for mistakes of
their past
and like that's not fair to the next guy
he didn't do anything to you yeah i
think a lot of times girls like do
exactly what you're saying like they put
so much into like a person that doesn't
appreciate it
um that they think the solution is to
not like don't do wifey things for like
for a boyfriend or whatever but i i see
girls that like put themselves out there
and like put their heart on the line
more like have better results yeah then
like the girls that just like close
themselves off and say like no
right and now i now i think it's still
good to be doing some of those things
but i think you have to do it with
caution like if you've only been seeing
someone for a little while you know
going and planning these extravagant
things is something that you would do in
a relationship so you don't want to do
that too early but i think right showing
how you want to be in a relationship in
like smaller increments and like seeing
how the person
receives it is a good indicator of like
will this be a good match for me because
i do think you don't want to put
all of your and i don't think you want
to put it all out there before you
decided to commit with someone because
there are people like you said who take
advantage of you and then it just but i
do think like if you authentically are
someone who like is very thoughtful and
you like
giving things to people like within
reason for me it's like oh i was at the
the bakery and i bought a cookie for you
that's like a small gesture that doesn't
mean anything for me i don't think
that's going out of my way to do
anything extravagant so it's like for me
i would do that on dates like oh yeah i
was at the bakery and i remember you
said your favorite he was chocolate so i
got for you but then there are some
people that would be like why did you
get me a cookie we're not dating you
know there are people like that they're
like well why did you do that like we've
only been on like a couple you know
there's something
so then it makes it hard because then
you're like well then i'm never doing
that again but i've just learned
keep being yourself authentically
because the right the right person will
eventually appreciate all of those
things that you've been doing and it'll
make you feel like oh yeah it was never
me it's just i wasn't meeting the right
people
um okay someone in the super or someone
sent in if they send me money i read
their questions yeah of course i'm
assuming assuming most both men were
equivalent would kesha prefer the man
who who quickly
verbally made the first move sexually or
the man who took it slow
i prefer the man who takes it slow
because i i like to take it slow i don't
like to rush into things so i like to
take my time for me if a man is trying
to push
uh something sexual too soon for me my
thought is they're just trying to get in
my pants that's right that's where my
brain is
i generally want to get to know someone
as a person before i even think about
that so i am team like let's just get to
know each other first also then it's
more meaningful and more fun when you
have a connection versus like you've
only been on two dates and like now
you're sleeping together i'm like uh i
don't even know you so i prefer the
person who does take take it slow
because that's how i like to operate as
well
yeah i agree um
okay i think that's all
women
i think there's one more oh women date
who they want men date who they can
um i'd say for some man it just depends
on the guy
yeah that's interesting
well i mean i think girls in general are
we're always going to have it like the
average girl is going to have way more
options than the average guy yeah that's
just
that that's just how it is yeah i think
so and i think the problem too
because obviously i know a lot of people
have issues with dating apps and yes
there are issues because there are a lot
of
you know people that are going to waste
your time but you have to think like it
really does make it easier to meet
people before dating apps like
what were we doing i'm like what were we
doing before
we were going to the bar but it's like
you don't always want to meet someone at
the bar because a lot of times most guys
at a bar just looking to take some drunk
girl home like
you do hear stories of like oh i met my
partner at a bar and like it wasn't like
that and yes that does still exist but
i just think we i just think people just
need to start changing their mindset and
like really believing that if they want
a per like a partner in life they can
have it you just have to be patient you
got to put in a little bit of work
and you know be intentional if you're
intentional with your dating i i truly
believe
people will find what they want but you
just have to be intentional don't just
swipe on a woman just so she's hot
because at the end of the day looks
aren't everything and
when we're 80 years old like i'm not
going to look like this when i'm 80.
like i'm in my prime right now but i
want someone to obviously i want the
person i'm with to find me attractive
and find me beautiful but what's more
important is like that they appreciate
me for my personality and my heart and
like what i have to give so like don't
just wipe on someone just because
they're attractive it's like yes it's
if they happen to be really attractive
like at the end of the day
well as women i think we all see that
girl like that friend or friend of a
friend that's an absolute wedge but guys
will date her because she's so actually
guys get blinded by it too sometimes
it's crazy i feel like when i was going
out which it's funny because a few
friends said that they felt that they
felt like i was that person for them
which i was like what i felt like going
out most of my life i was the ugly
friend i felt like i would go out with
friends and they were constantly being
hit on by men and i was left at the bar
awkward by myself and that was a lot of
my real life experience people looking
at me now would probably be like what
are you talking about but that was a lot
of my
my personal experience for a lot of life
so i i was like oh so then you see your
hot friend getting all the attention
you're like what am i trouble ever like
i have good things to offer you know and
so it's not always about the looks but
yeah men i think get blinded
and you know it's hard you got your beer
goggles on so then
um okay so you said date intentionally
intentionally what i started doing if
you're if you are using dating apps this
is one of the things that i found made a
difference
get off tinder i'm sorry if you want to
meet a partner stop using tinder my
number one rule because most of tinder
is just hookups whether you want to
believe it or not so get off tinder if
you actually want to meet a person
uh i recommend hinge or bumble i'm team
hinge because i think you get a little
bit more serious staters
for me what helped weed out people who
weren't in alignment with what i what i
wanted i started doing virtual dates so
on my profile it said as one of the
prompts the best way to ask me out is
either by a virtual date or a phone call
so if they asked for a phone call i
always countered for a virtual date and
every time i counted for a virtual date
it worked 100 of the time for me if a
man is gonna take time out of his day to
set up a virtual date he's probably a
little bit more serious he's probably
not an f boy he's probably not just
looking for something casual so for me
that's how i was able to weed out more
people and if someone asked me out like
i did have a few people before
the electrician where we were chatting
for a while and i was hoping we would
set up a virtual date and they were just
like hey i'm going to be in a store
would you like to grab a drink and i
said i'm actually doing virtual dates as
the first meeting it says it on my
profile if you're up for that let me
know and they unmatch me so those people
obviously didn't read my profile and i
know we're not looking for anything
because as soon as i said virtual date
they pieced out
and i think a virtual date is good for
men too you want to know like
if you have something in common with the
girl
well also too i realized by doing the
virtual date a it's very low key you
don't have to leave your play you don't
have to leave your apartment
there are fun things you can do like you
can still have a drink at home you can
do like show and tell like on i did a
date where we both had cats and we did
like show and tell of our cats
um you can like cook dinner together if
it's like a few dates in where you're
like both cooking dinner together there
are creative things you can do but also
i just realized out of all of the
in-person first dates i went on had i
set up a virtual date
i would have never ended up on a first
date with them because i would have
realized we were not compatible for me
that alone was a time saver because how
many times have we all been on an
awkward first date where you know
in the first five minutes that it's not
going to go well and then it's awkward
then it's like when the server comes to
say oh do you want another drink and if
one person says yes and the other person
says no then it's like
i've been there one too many times so
it's like the virtual date eliminates
all that and there's no pressure like if
one person didn't enjoy it
be like oh sorry i gotta go
xyz and hang up the phone like
it just takes the pressure off and i
think it's a little bit more low-key but
for me
i just noticed people who were more
intentional with what they wanted were
willing to set up virtual dates and
because that's what i wanted
that helped me personally so i'm i'm a
fan of that yeah swipe intentionally
virtual dates and i think it's helpful
sit down write a list of all the
qualities you want in a partner like get
specific of the things you want
put it in an envelope seal it and put it
away don't look at it
and then trust and know that everything
you want in a partner is already on your
way to you i'm big on the law of
attraction and big on like operating at
a high vibrational frequency which is
why i think i've been having a really
good year because i've just been tapping
into that
so trust that everything you want is
already on its way to you and just keep
taking steps towards that and eventually
you'll you know you'll it might take you
it took me a long time it took me nine
years of dating in new york to get to
where i am now
but
had i not had all of those crappy dating
experiences i would have never done
stain of comedy i would have never had
inspiration to write one of the sketches
i wrote so for me i'm a firm believer in
the journey so i have zero regrets that
it took me this long to get here because
it made this moment worth it and i would
have never met him or even if i met him
years ago he would not have been this
version and i would not have been this
version of myself so i'm a firm believer
that everything happens in the right
time
and just you just have to trust in that
fact and like stay positive it's hard
some days but if you just kind of stay
open and positive and like
try not to like hate math
yeah
no i definitely agree like i could just
tell based on your tick tocks i was like
she's gonna find someone like she's nice
she's friendly she's in good shape like
she's gonna find someone yeah and people
have been with me along the way like i
didn't realize how cuz sometimes you're
like does anybody watch my videos but
when i made the video posting the
official
so many of my followers were like oh my
god i've been watching you from the
beginning like i remember when you
started this journey so they've got to
see everything so that was really cool
for me too so
yeah
um well thank you so much i try to keep
um my interviews around an hour no
that's good i figured
um thank you so much for coming on thank
you so much for having me this was so
much fun i hope people learn some things
i know not everyone probably agreed with
my dating advice but this is what worked
for me if you want to go on my tic toc
and snoop and see what other advice i'm
giving you can also get out there
yeah um send me any links you want me to
put in the description well it takes
like a day or two to load but um you
just send me the links and i'll put it
in the description but thank you so much
thank you for having me
all right guys before we end the podcast
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell and
i will talk to you guys next